hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar deep
immunophenotyping of cancer
microenvironments
by imaging mass cytometry i am tracy
aston martin of labyrinths
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by
fluidine now let's get started
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i now present today's speaker dr noel
d miranda a principal investigator in
the department of pathology
at the leiden university medical center
and a project leader
for the immunogenomics group his group
aims to develop innovative therapies
that are focused on stimulating a
patient's immune system
to recognize and eliminate cancer cells
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen noelle
you may now begin your presentation
many thanks for the introduction i will
indeed show a bit of our work
where we've been applying imaging
methodology to characterize
microenvironmental cancers with a
particular focus on interactions between
immune cell
and tumor cells i will start by
acknowledging the people that are
actually doing the work medic isil
science is the phd student that set up
the imaging methodology panel for ffp
tissues
at the lmc and antonio somerakas has
developed a number of image analysis
tools that will be discussed in this
presentation uh we also worked in close
collaboration with the groups of
fresconing who has really been
instrumental
in bringing this technology into the lmc
um
and about buying liverpool who had the
division of imaging
processing at the lmc
so why focus on cancer microenvironments
and in particular
in the immune cell component of cancer
microenvironments
it is now well accepted that the
quantitative and qualitative composition
of the immune system in the tumor is a
major determinant of clinical behavior
with the presence of different immune
cells being associated with either
improved or worse clinical outcomes
depending on which
immune cell subsides you're looking at
um and there's really been a renewed
interest in cancer immunology in the
last decade
um as a result of the successful
development of therapeutic antibiotics
targeting coenactory
receptor in t-cells like the ones
mediated by
pd-1 and ctla-4 receptors
these therapies have been particularly
successful in terms with a strong
immunogenic profile
which is connected to the accumulation
of large numbers of somatic mutations
throughout their genius the elevator
number of mutations then translates to
an increased likeness
that t-cells will be able to identify
and eliminate
tumor cells accordingly
what you also see is that tumors with
more mutations are generally
more densely infiltrated in particular
by
uh cda positive
the determinant response however are not
limited to mutation burden and
infiltration by t
cell as it can be deduced by the fact
that only a minority of patients
with theoretically immunogenic tumors
are currently responding to checkpoint
therapists
in fact as depicted in the cancer
immunogram put forward by some of our
colleagues at mci
together with anthony rivas another
model that in the meantime
has been proposed there's really a
myriad of methods of play that influence
immune responses to immunotherapy
and which need to be considered that
include the presence
and functional state of other immune
cells than just t
cells or cytotoxicity um
so it has been very exciting to see
throughout the years how technology has
evolved and made it possible to look
deeper
into tumors and to multiple features
simultaneously
by both methods in particular with both
rna sequencing
we can assess transcriptional programs
of cancer and groups have developed
tools to inform
on immune cell composition of tumors
based on these data
however such analysis are restricted to
averages
or approximations of immune cell
composition
and do not really allow for the
investigation of complexity
and certainly not a single cell level
more recently single cell sequencing and
other single cell technologies have
already been a major breakthrough in the
sense that
they provided us with the ability to
characterize in detail
the phenotypes but also genetic features
however one must not forget that such
technique does not include
uh the spatial contextual cell and there
are bias
associated uh to our ability to retrieve
certain immune cell subsides from
tissues
particularly when we're talking uh about
solid tumors it can be quite challenging
to retrieve
all subsets that are contained within
the german micro environment
and so to address these insufficiencies
it is fundamental that we can make use
of multiplex imaging technologies that
not only form on the phenotypes itself
but also their rotation between the
tissue and the cellular contacts they're
inserted in
several groups like the ones for
instance your home gallon video
municipal have now demonstrated that
different tumors can carry the same
amount of t
salt for instance but their differential
localization can have profound clinical
implications which would not be picked
up
by methods that ignores spatial contacts
we are therefore very lucky that we can
make use
of an emission mathematical instrument
of dnc
where the parallel detection of several
engines can be done simultaneously
by making use of having methyl labeled
antibodies
so in the past years we've been working
very hard to set up a panel of around 40
markers
and the description of this process was
published at the end of last year
we went ahead with labeling each and
every tone that was probably
previously tested by us by standard
immune system chemistry
and this is because we wanted to have
flexibility to combine specific
antibodies
with particular metal attacks and during
this process
we realized a few important things first
that a mixture for the antibiotics is
not
performed very well in one go and that
antibodies also perform best in
different conditions
different types of and to address these
two issues we made use of
two sequential incubation steps one
overnight
and four degrees and the other was room
temperature and we distributed the
antibodies by these two conditions
according to their performance and
thereby also splitting the total amount
of antibodies for two incubations
so our current panel includes a number
of immune cell image markers so it has
been updated since
the publication of our paper that
includes the number of immune cell image
markers
differentiation and activation markers
um
immunomodulator molecules including
therapeutic targets
some signaling molecules and finally and
also very importantly some structural
markers
that allow us to map the tissue for the
different components as well to
distinguish epithelial terms from
layers we make use of a number of
in-house developed tools
as well as tools that are publicly
available for processing
of the data so we start with inspecting
the quality of the antibody signal
with the mcd viewer and if that looks
good we develop cell mass
and perform background subtraction by
making use of cell profiler
and elastic we then transformed this
imaging data into a personal matrix that
is used as an input for cytospore
or with tsna based dimensionality
reduction we identify
cell clusters that can correspond to a
cell substance
um the biological validation is such
that
some further analysis are then conducted
with hemocytes just to give you an
example
um with hemocyte we can inspect the
presence of a particular cell cluster
in the in the masks that we apply to the
images
and evaluate whether that cluster has
indeed the morphology
and distribution that was expected
so a tumor cell should look like a tumor
cell and my lifestyle like a myeloid
solvent
like a lymphocyte
a lot of our work focuses on fluorescent
cancer
and you can divide fluorescent cancers
in four major molecular systems
according to their transitional profiles
where you have a group that shows high
immunogenicity
and consequence infiltration by factor
immune cells
the cms1 type the cms2 and 3 which are
subsidized characterized by very poor
immune cell infiltration and driven by
wind and make activation and metabolism
dysregulation
respectively and a fourth subtype which
does demonstrate some type of
inflammatory process going on
but the microenvironment is largely
dominated by atg beta
stromal signature so
we wanted to know whether we could see
certain critical profiles reflected
on the analysis that we conducted with
uh
imaging massachusetts we processed some
samples by this methodology
uh and through uh through the
analysis approach that i explained
before we define the following clusters
where
i confess we adjusted a rather
conservative approach
by defining too many subsets
so we identified for instance 21
turmeric cell
clusters 13 different lymphocytes cell
clusters 14 myeloid clusters
eight uh strong subsets and
and seven types of cells which we cannot
really give it
easy biological meaning to those
so despite being rather conservative we
thought this number of subsets
already gave a nice structure and
complexity to states that
to perform subsequent analysis
so some of the findings were not very
surprising mainly that t-cell
infiltration particularly by activated
cytotoxic t-cells
is really a hallmark of the cms-1 type
but perhaps a bit more surprising uh is
the fact that
immune reaction is accompanied by a very
proponent filtration by granulocytic
immune cells
and we still really have to understand
uh what is the meaning of their presence
and how they intervene in the context of
checkpoint logic therapy
for instance and one of the coolest
things
of this technology in my opinion is our
ability to distinguish
tumor associated my life success namely
different flavors of macrophages
monocyte synthetic cells
which i think is quite challenging to do
with other technologies normally single
cell technologies
and it's really nice to see in the
images the complexity
uh or we know that these subsets are
really complex and it's very nice of
seeing the images indeed
all these different shades of myelin
cells which have not always been
captured
uh with previous uh with previous
approaches finally
it is also extremely interesting to
study how the accumulation of immune
cell
associates the features of tumor or
thermal cells for instance the relation
between immune cell infiltration
and the presence of tj beta related
molecules
in the micro environment an additional
bonus
uh of the multiplex technologies
is that it also allows you to discover
things like chance and stuff that you
are not really
able to immediately explain based on
current knowledge like it is the case
when we find success through the
combination of markers that were not
anticipated to go together and here of
course you
you run the chance of been looking at
artifacts so
one really needs to make sure we
validate whether these subsets
are really meaningful and distinguishing
a true immune cell
population but once we see that these
are typical
uh particular sub types of polarized
cancer we think there might be an
interesting biological meaning to them
finally the imaging also allows us to
identify to investigate in depth uh what
is the relation between all subsets that
have
been that i've been identified uh and
whether differences in the spatial
arrangements
of cell success also play a role
uh in pathogenesis um and this is a
glimpse of what we've been doing in
addition to numerous projects
that are currently ongoing um
in combination with the clinics to try
to extract information
that is available in different tumor
types and particularly in the context
of checkpoint blockage treatments of
cancer patients that are undergoing
immunotherapy
in the coming years we will probably be
working very hard on the integration of
states that derive from
different multiplex platforms and we
think that imc
can really play an important role in for
instance supporting the mapping back of
single cell data or the mapping of
single cell data
back to tissues
and i'll finish my presentation here
the same way i started by acknowledging
the people that are actually doing the
work and i'm more than happy
to answer questions that might come my
way
thank you
thank you noelle for your informative
presentation we will now start the q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
so let's get started
let's see what we have
for questions
we have quite a few questions coming in
we'll start with our first
question have you been using
imc for other purposes than
immune oncology
um yeah so the lab has has been
employing
imaging mass psychometry um in other
projects as well
um basically
any setting that requires the use of
multiple markers
to assess a phenotype of a cell so for
instance we also have
a project that is focusing on signaling
and there what we have built is a panel
that is mostly
constituted by fossil specific
antibodies to study signaling
in tumors
our next question how do you see the
integration
of single cell sequencing with imc going
forward
yeah so as discussed in the in the
presentation
um there are some advantages to using
single cell technologies
another using imaging uh imaging mass
cytometry
but in the lab we also see both as
highly complement
com complementary so what we've been
trying to do
is to project single cell sequencing
data on gene expression
back to the images
and what we do is you use common markers
between the single cell data
and the imaging data and you determine
the probability that a certain cell from
single cell sequencing belongs
to a certain part of the tissue and this
is easier
to be done if there are some common
markers for instance in the setting of
sightseeing where you could use the same
antibody
that you use for imc as that you use for
for for sightseeing
and these are attempts to try to
increase
the amount of information we can get
from a cell by joining
these gene expression profiles
or with with their spatial localization
thank you noelle our next question
do you develop the analysis pipeline
yourself
a custom solution or use something that
is commercially available
yeah so for the cell masks um
for creating cell masks and for
determining what's real signal and
what's background signal
uh we use uh uh tools that are
that are available like cell profiler
are elastic but we are lucky enough that
we have
a division of image processing in the
at the lmc and that's a research group
on itself so we're very
lucky to be able to rely on those guys
to develop solutions
for the analysis of data but there are
also tools which are available
off the shelf for the processing of imc
data
like the ones developed by the bode
miller lab like histocat for instance
okay thank you
is imc applicable to other tissue types
or
just for ffpe um
it really shouldn't matter um so we also
use
uh imaging mass spectrometry panels on
uh snap frozen tissue
uh what one has to to realize
is that um the the panel of antibodies
will not be the same for
ffe um and for a frozen tissue
and that has to do with the availability
of the antigens
so for instance if you're used to use
applications like flow cytometry
if you want to use the same clones those
will be more likely to work
on on frozen tissue while for ffbe won't
you probably have to
to select a number of specific clones
that will only work on ffbe and not on
presentation
okay wonderful well it looks like that's
all the time we have today
uh thank you again dr noel d miranda for
your time today
in your important research before we go
i'd like to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
oh we just got one more question that
just came in so i'm going to uh
i'm going gonna i'm gonna go off the
rails and ask this question this is an
important question
are the metal
conjugation kits easy to work with did i
pronounce that correctly are the metal
um we do all the labeling ourselves
um so we had to rely heavily on the
conjugation kits i think it's quite
straightforward to use
i mean uh as everything in the lab it
requires a bit of accuracy and
it takes a bit of time but it's it's
quite straightforward you should be able
to easily do it yourself
it's just following a protocol and of
course you need to get the antibodies
on a special formulation because they
cannot have stuff like bsa
or other proteins otherwise i'll be
labeling those rather than the antibody
itself
okay great again thank you again uh dr
miranda
for your time today and for your
important research before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those that are submitted
during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provide at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through july 2021
until next time be safe everybody have a
great day and goodbye